[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on
sunday who'd be a pundit in these
uncertain times
a week ago we spent the whole show
talking about matt hancock
a bloke who admitted to letting the
nation down while playing away from home
this morning we're celebrating a whole
team that also played away
but made us proud at wimbledon instead
of the usual
sunday morning blues that all the plucky
brits have been knocked out in the first
seven days there's news that a british
woman emma radukanu
has made it into the second week in
politics to most people's surprise
labor held battley and spen and we
awakened this morning to the sound of
downing street whispers
that the hitherto cautious prime
minister may be about to let us
ditch the masks and go back to spending
saturday night
clubbing as we all do here before coming
in to chart the road
ahead for you your regular sunday
morning political
sat nav so after two by-election defeats
are the wheels coming off the johnson
bus the housing secretary robert
generic will be with us in a moment
shadow chancellor rachel reeves on why
labour thinks they're
back on the road to number 10.
northern ireland's democratic unionist
parties had some trouble deciding who
should be at the wheel in recent times
but in his first television interview
since becoming leader
sir jeffrey donaldson tells our senior
ireland correspondent
david blevins how he sees the way ahead
plus i'll ask adam finn who's a member
of the joint committee on vaccination at
immunization
if we're still cruising towards the
easing of lockdown on july the 19th
and a broadcast exclusive the veteran
american pollster frank
luntz on a new survey of the
electorate's mood
there may be trouble ahead
but first the housing secretary robert
generic joins me
mr generic the new health secretary says
in an article this morning
that we have to learn to accept the
existence of covid
just as we do with the flu now according
to the
office for national statistics there are
some 20 000
deaths associated with fluids in a
typical year are we now saying
that that annual toll with covid
is inevitable hi well good morning
trevor
i think we are now reaching a different
phase in the virus
we're not going to put the covert 19
virus behind us forever we're going to
have to learn
to live with it but thanks to the
enormous success of our vaccine
program the fact that now we've got to
the point where 83
of adults in this country have had at
least one jab
we should be able to think about how we
can return
to normality as much as possible and the
data that we're seeing that the prime
minister is reviewing
at the moment ahead of his decision
point on the road map
looks very positive it does seem as if
we can now move forward and move to a
much more permissive
regime where we move away from many of
those restrictions that have been so
difficult for us
and as you say learn to live with the
virus
that does mean that we're going to have
to treat it carefully we're going to
have to keep on
monitoring the cases and we're going to
have to ensure that every adult
gets double vaxxed because that is the
key to keeping the
virus under control as we move into the
autumn and the winter
that's admirably clear and it looks as
though you
are following the prime minister's
suggestion that um
we will be put lifting the uh
restrictions
but the bma the british medical
association is urging
caution for example keeping the
requirement for face masks in public
places
now um mr general will you be dumping
your mask on july the 20th
well like many people i want to get away
from these restrictions as quickly as i
possibly can
and we don't want them to stay in place
for a day longer
than is necessary we are going to i
think now move into a period
where there won't be legal restrictions
the state won't be telling you what to
do but you will want to exercise
a degree of personal responsibility and
judgment so different people will come
to different conclusions on things like
masks for example and the prime minister
will set out more detail on
the the national policy on some of those
restrictions in
the coming days but there will be things
that we all
definitely need to do as i say it will
be essential
that every adult gets fully vaccinated
and there are still people
in the most significant categories
categories 1 to 9
who haven't been vaccinated 50 000
people in those categories got
vaccinated
in the last week they've come forward
relatively late in the process but
it's really important that we get those
remaining people
vaccinated it will also be important
that we do things like
making sure that the most vulnerable get
their flu vaccinations
this autumn and winter because that will
be a big issue there will be things we
need to do as a society
we get through this before we cut before
we go on to that can we just deal with a
question i
asked you if you are permitted will
you be getting rid of your mask
i i will i i don't particularly want to
wear a mask i
don't think a lot of people uh enjoy
doing it
we will be moving into a phase though
where these will be matters of personal
choice
and so some mems society will want to do
so
for perfectly legitimate reasons but it
will be a different
period where we as private citizens
make these judgments rather than the
government telling you what to do
okay now apparently today is national
thank you day whose idea was that and
um what would you the government like
nation to be doing once they stopped
watching this program
well it was actually a bottom-up idea it
came from local communities
they came together and established this
idea that
this is a moment in which we can all go
and say a big thank you to those who've
helped us
in our daily lives over the course of
the last year perhaps those people
who've gone out of their
way to support the community through
covert 19 or others
who've done good work the prime minister
will be hosting
some of those who've helped us through
the pandemic at number 10
and i know people in my own community
that i would like to say
a big thank you to isn't this a bit
previous
you've just advised me to wait for the
prime minister's
statement on july the 19th but you're
encouraging everybody to
barbecue today i mean couldn't this have
waited a couple of weeks until
we actually know what the guidance is
going to be
isn't this yet another case of the
government sending mixed messages
no the government didn't create uh
national thank you day it's actually
been created by memphis
beckett you didn't have to back it today
we can say thank you any time in the
next
six months if we want to well as i say
the government didn't create this day
it's been created by
members of the public who themselves
wanted to say thank you of course
uh there are guidelines in place that
you have to follow if you're
holding an event today and i'm sure the
prime minister and others who
who are doing so will make sure that
they are followed but the point of the
day
uh is for those of us who benefited from
the hard work and compassion empathy
that others have provided over the
course of last year
to reach out to them and say thank you
and that can be done in many ways
there may be some people who are holding
socially distanced get-togethers
but there'll be plenty of other people
who might use this opportunity simply to
pick up the phone to somebody
who's done good work and really help
them out over the course of the last
year
yes indeed we can say thank you in many
ways wouldn't one way
be for the health secretary or the prime
minister
to pick up the phone to the let's say
the royal college of nursing or the bma
and say you know what we've decided that
one percent
pay rise which is below inflation is
going to be boosted
by two or three percent that would be a
real way to say thank you wouldn't it
well we all want to reward those people
who've worked in the nhs and social
carers local government secretary
i feel very strongly about that that at
the moment is a topic for the
independent pay review body
who will be providing advice to the
health secretary
and the government in the coming months
and armed with that
we'll make a decision but it's only in
my role i've always
driven to provide local government with
the resources it needs
to fund social care we've done that over
the course of the pandemic we've now
done it
with two record-breaking settlements for
the local government sector since boris
johnson became
prime minister and i very much hope will
be in a position to do that in the
future
so uh we're not stuck to the one percent
it could be higher
in the end well the process is that
uh the recommendation is judged by the
independent pay review body and then it
comes to ministers for a final
decision so nothing is is set in stone
but we as ministers will have to wait
for the advice that we receive from the
pay review body and that's the right
thing to do
right well let's keep talking about how
we say thank you you say in your release
that you want to thank people who have
provided refuge with women
facing domestic abuse which everybody
agrees
has risen during lockdown so
now women who are afraid to venture out
onto the high street
in case they run into their abusers are
being urged
to rock up today to a cheery barbecue
whilst having nowhere to go
later because of lack of funds for
refugees now that would be a good way of
saying thank you and that's
i think that's in your baileywick isn't
it why not say thank you today
with some more money for uh domestic
abuse refuges for the women who have
suffered violence
well trevor we are doing that uh we
passed the domestic abuse act
earlier in the year which is a landmark
piece of legislation
to ensure that women and men who are
victims of domestic abuse
get the support that they need in safe
and secure accommodation
such as refuges we've fully funded that
major commitment
with 125 million pounds and that money
is now with local councils
who are ensuring that local services get
the support that they need and in fact i
spoke
last week at the women's aid conference
to the brilliant people who run those
refuges
across the country to say thank you to
them and also
wrote to every local council in the
country urging them
to use that money wisely and amongst
other services that they commission
to make sure that they properly fund
women's refuges
because they do a fantastic job they
have often been funded in quite a
hand-to-mouth way in recent decades that
needs to come to an
end now that we've got this very
significant amount of extra funding
available for them did um the leaders of
women's
aid read out to you what they said in
their report a couple of months ago
which is uh the 90 million announced in
the budget
today is not enough they then go on to
say
that they need 393 million
pounds uh for of funding and that there
is a shortfall of 200 million
pounds in the government's current plans
what are you going to do about that well
i i don't recognize those numbers
they're not ones i've actually seen
the the amount of funding the amount of
funding i'm reading it out to you
i understand that but the amount of
money that we've provided 125 million
pounds
is actually considered to be fully
funding
the refuge and domestic uh abuse
uh duties that now fall on local houses
but not by women's aid
well i had i had very good conversation
with
the chief executive women's aide and
with representatives
of those who run refuges during the week
they appreciate the funding of course
people would always like to have
more money but this is a very
significant increase in the amount of
funding
that any government has given in the
past for women's refugees and for other
services
that will be provided for victims of
domestic abuse
the key thing now is to make sure that
councils
perform their duties under this new
piece of legislation correctly
and they include giving women and other
victims of domestic abuse priority
for social housing if they need to leave
their home
ensuring that they get the support
services that they need that can be
delivered in many different settings and
as i say making sure that refuges
across the country are put on a
sustainable financial footing
so we don't see the situation that
afraid we have done in the past
which is where some of those refugees
are having to kind of survive
year in year out with too little money
and not
long-term sustainable funding we're
going to change that
well perhaps you need to have another
conversation with them but let's let's
talk about um
batley and spence um you lost when you
might have won do you blame matt hancock
well of course i'm disappointed that we
lost we had a great candidate ryan
stevens and i'd love to have seen him
in parliament but governments very very
rarely
take seats off oppositions in
by-elections in fact there's only been
one
instance in recent years which was
hartley paul which was an exceptional
result actually this was the biggest
swing
from an opposition to the party of
government
for 39 years so in my lifetime
so it was still a fantastic result for
the conservative party albeit not
exactly what we would have hoped for and
i think there are a lot of questions for
kia stammer as to how the labour party
are just scraping home by 300 or so
votes
when they should be romping home in
these sorts of elections
okay well um here's a question for you
um
given that you had a 8 000 vote leg up
from
george galloway who took votes from
labor
um actually it wasn't that good a result
for you um and surely there's something
more fundamental going on here as there
was in cheshium
and amisham could it be that um like in
cheshire many people in those
very pretty villages uh around batley
think that your planning reforms mean
that
your idea of leveling up is allowing
developers to concrete
over their villages and fields
no i don't agree with that at all i mean
on the question of
the by-elections as i say government
extremely rarely take seats off
the opposition in by-elections of course
it was also disappointing result in
cheshire and amisham
but the argument put out there very
disingenuously by the lib dems that
there were
huge amounts of houses being built in
that area was simply untrue
last year only a hundred houses were
built in the cheshire
amisham constituency which i think was
the 10th
lowest of any local authority in the
whole country
what we want to see are good quality
environmentally sustainable homes with
the infrastructure around them
being built across the country so that
young people
and families can get onto the housing
ladder that's absolutely critical
to leveling up to tackling
intergenerational
unfairnesses in this country and we're
going to
redouble our efforts to build those
homes but do so in a way that protects
green spaces
they won't be being built on the green
belt and we want to make a planning
system
which is much more engaging than the
current one in which only one or two
percent
of the public have any contact with in
their lifetimes
when we're talking about um leveling up
on friday you were in a place called
kidsgrove which is near stoke on trent
you were talking about the importance of
the investments that you're making
locally and you tweeted leveling up in
action
where 20 17 million pounds of investment
from the towns fund
has enabled the reopening of the sports
center
there in kidsgrove um would it not have
been
simpler if the conservative-led
staffordshire county council hadn't
withdrawn their substitute subsidy in
2017
to that sports center in the first place
then you wouldn't have had to make that
investment
well the towns fund is part of our now
almost 10 billion pound investment into
towns and smaller cities across the
country
aim to improve living standards improve
quality of life
and i was really pleased to go to to
kidsgrove by stoke on trent
as you say on friday and see how it's
impacting people's lives
there the decision actually was taken by
a labour council
there uh it was very unfortunate as a
result of the town's fund we're changing
that
and that sports centre is being brought
back into community use
as we speak and i'm hoping that we'll be
able to do more things like that across
the country
particularly examples like that where
it's actually community
ownership that's a sports centre that's
going to be run by the local community
itself not by a council
but by a group of engaged local
residents coming together and we're
putting
funding available for those sorts of
schemes to happen right across the
country
one last very quick question if i may uh
mr generic
um last week was the fourth anniversary
of the awful events at the grenfell
tower and the government has been making
quite a lot of money available
to repair cladding but the estimates
uh to deal with the
range of buildings across the country
um are as high as 15 billion
pounds and you've made about three and a
half billion pounds available
that means that many uh flat owners
across the country are having to pay and
we've seen
lots of reports this week are having to
pay
the price of their entire properties
in order to repair the cladding that
surely
cannot be right well i have huge
sympathy with those uh
leaseholders who are placed in an
impossible situation the government is
actually putting over five billion
pounds
uh towards this issue we're ensuring
that the most dangerous material
acm cladding and other unsafe forms of
cladding are removed from all high-rise
buildings in the country
at no cost to leaseholders that work is
underway now we're making
good progress we're also
trying to ensure there's a much more
sensible and proportionate approach
to risk on other buildings particularly
the lower rise ones
because we are seeing examples of
leaseholders being asked to pay bills
for works which seem to be unnecessary
there's no actually higher risk of an
individual
living in a a purpose-built flat or a
high-rise building than in any other
building
in fact more people die in fires in
houses and bungalows
than they do in high-rise apartments so
we're working with lenders and insurers
and surveyors
to try to create a much more sensible
and proportionate way forwards
mr generic thank you very much indeed
now hanging on to baton span may have
eased the pressure on the labour leader
kyostama for now but even his deputy
says that people don't quite know what
he stands for
and an exclusive poll for sky news found
this week that 7 out of 10
labour members would prefer to see the
mayor of greater manchester andy burnham
as leader how long before another
leadership
challenge let's ask sakir's most scenic
shadow cabinet colleague rachel reeves
rachel reeves um batman span a narrow
squeak but you won
peter mandelson says this gives uh sakir
until
september to come up with a case for
remaining
leader of the party um do you agree
well it was a great result in batley and
spain and i can't tell you
how pleased i am that kim ledbeter is
going to be joining me
in parliament on monday tomorrow as the
member of parliament for batley and
spain and it's a seat that means so much
to all of us
in the labour party and kim is an
inspiration she will
shake up westminster in every good
possible way
and that by-election which i fought hard
in as well is very near to me
in leeds west was a a by-election like
none other that i have seen during my 25
years
involved in the labour party and in
politics
it was a a campaign full of so much
hatred and
division stoked by people from outside
of batley and spend
and that victory on the in the early
hours of friday morning was a victory
for decency over division
for hope over hatred and for integrity
in politics and
that is the labour party that kia
stammer stands for
and it is the labour party that is
embodied
by the campaign that kim and the team
ran in batley and spence so
i am delighted by the result and can't
wait to see kim
get started as mp in westminster and in
her community
i fully understand that but do you agree
with the mandelson deadline
of september look kia is
elected as leader of the labour party
today i'm setting out
ambitious plans for labour for how as
chancellor i would ensure that we buy
make and sell more
in britain and i think that the party in
batley and spend came together
under kia's leadership with kim as the
candidate it showed
everything that is best about the labour
party uh and
under kia's leadership and with kim in
parliament i think that we can
build on that success in batley and
spend going into the summer
then with our party conference and then
uh campaigning at the next general
election
lightweight campaigns in batley and
spend go on for more victories going
forward
okay well you're not disagreeing with
with lord mandelson but you are
stressing the excellence of york you're
you're stressing the excellence
of your candidate um no key
yeah under kyr's leadership we won in
badly and spent
a kia will take us into the next
election and i believe that that result
in the early hours of friday morning is
the start of
more victories for labour all right
before we leave batman spend
you spoke of uh the hatred and division
being sowed
in that election campaign as did sakir
on friday morning who exactly was sowing
hatred and division
well i mean i was there on many
occasions
and i saw some of the behaviors of
george galloway
and his campaign uh and the
violence and aggression shown towards
both kim and other labour actors
there is no place for the sort of
behavior that we saw in batley and spain
in any election but especially in a
place like batley and spain that has
been through
so much in the last five years or so and
deserved
so much better than what they saw during
this by-election campaign and the people
of battle and spain rejected that
and they voted for kim and kim is now
their mp and i know that kim would do
everything in her power to bring the
community together
as she has over the last five years
running
schemes like mooring common batley and
spen and i am so proud
of kim but also of the people of batley
and then
thank you for being so clear in pointing
the finger at
mr galloway does that mean that either
the 8
200 and odd people who voted for him
didn't realize what he was about or that
they actually like the idea of hatred
and division what what's going on there
there was a huge amount of fake news
being pushed out in that constituency
and there was the whipping up of
tensions that has no place in our
democracy
kim now has a job to do to bring that
community together
i know that she can do that and will
start on that work
immediately i don't um
hold against anyone for voting for
different parties but the role of an mp
is to bring communities together whoever
they voted for
and show that decency and hope and
integrity can triumph
as it did in batley and spain last week
there is something that that comes out
of this um
whole well two things that come out of
this uh campaign first of all um
labour party issued a leaflet showing
boris johnson
and narendra modi the prime minister of
india together with a caption saying
don't risk a tory mp who is not on your
side what was that about
why mr modi
well if you look at some of the actions
by boris johnson
during the course of this pandemic but
one of the things that
stands out very sharply is the failure
to close the borders properly to protect
us from new variants of the virus
including the delta
variant and the prime minister prime
minister johnson wanted his
trade uh visit to india to get
a trade deal but he put at risk
the vaccine roll out and allowed new
variants to enter
the country that is not responsible that
is not acting in
the national interest and labor called
on the government to close down
that border to protect the uk long
before the prime minister
eventually woke up to the reality the
rising number of cases
and the risk to our successful
vaccination program
it is unusual to have a foreign leader
on the
leaflets of a candidate in a local
by election uh i just want you to clear
up
the labor view on the allegation that
this was
i think the words are being used are dog
whistle uh
to muslim voters that um actually
the tories are in some way anti-muslim
and that they identify with um what is
said to be an anti-muslim government
led by mr modi there's none of that
going on here
i don't um accept that um
that that that insinuation um trevor
and what we saw in batley and spain was
underhand tactics by galloway and his
campaign
bringing people from outside to whip up
that hatred and division
with actual violence and aggression
towards the labor candidate
harassing intimidating chasing her down
the street and also to labor
activists that is the true nature of
what was happening
in batley and spain but the people of
that community rose above that
and returned kim as their mp last week
that is a great result
for labour it's also a great result for
batley and sven
all right let's talk about what you want
to talk about today which is
the pr your promise that the labor
government would make buy and sell
more in britain and that you bring more
jobs home is this some an update to
gordon brown's pledge
of british jobs for british workers
it's very different from that this is
about a post-pandemic recovery plan
and how as chancellor i would ensure
that we support
high street small businesses and jobs
and industry
across the united kingdom as we address
some of the big challenges that we
face as a country and i put together a
three-point plan
to buy make and sell more in britain
and that includes using all the tools at
government's disposal
to do so so for example with procurement
to use stretching targets in procurement
to
award more contracts to companies are
creating jobs and skills and
apprenticeships
here in britain to help businesses who
want
post-pandemic and also post-brexit to
reassure jobs to make their
supply chains more secure and resilient
to help them to do that
and also to sort out the big gaping
holes
in the brexit deal that the government
signed last year
to make it easier for british industries
and workers to export goods and services
across the european union
especially in our creative industries
professional services
and in farming and fisheries as well and
with that three-point plan
we can ensure that we're buying making
and selling more in this country
ensuring that the uk economy is firing
on all cylinders
and that we are more secure and more
resilient in face of the sorts of shocks
that any economy uh and especially one
that's been through everything we've
been through
in the last year and a half to ensure
that we are more secure and resilient in
the face of those shocks
i i think this is what um distinguished
economies economists like yourself call
a non-tariff barrier so let's take an
example and see how this would work in
reality um biggest construction project
in the country pretty much hs2 high
speed
line six months ago the bosses of hs2
picked a small group of construction
companies uh
to compete for contracts worth two and a
half
billion pounds for new rail lines now
just
one of the companies they picked is
british
would your proposals mean that hs2
when they make their decision would be
more likely
to pick the british company
i think that's a really good example
trevor because whether or not you think
that hs2
should go ahead and i know there are big
differences of opinion on that
i think we can all agree that that
investment should benefit
jobs skills apprenticeships and
businesses here
in britain because it is in our national
interest to create those high skill
well-paid jobs and what my proposals
that i
am setting out today of how i would
approach this as chancellor of the
exchequer
would say that when you look at the
different bids that come in for any
project whether it be hs2 or offshore
wind or whatever it is
you can look at the plans of the
businesses bidding for that contract
to see what impact it would have on the
wider uk economy what strategic
value a bid has and if it is creating
jobs
in this country high skilled well-paid
jobs and apprenticeships
and that means that we're building up
that skill set so we can export around
the world
those bids should get more weight than
bids that are creating no jobs no skills
and no
investment in this country so it's not
saying that we won't give
contracts to to foreign companies
absolutely not but it is saying like in
france and like in the united states
we would take into account the social
impact of
any public procurement other countries
do that because they know it is
strategically important
and yet in the uk we don't use those
powers that we have at our disposal and
that is a mistake and i would do that
differently
so you you say this is a good example um
so as chancellor what you would do is
create an environment in which
the in that case the british company
balfour beatty would
be favored so you would be leaning on
hs2 bosses
toward the contract to a company
implicated in the 2005 hatfield rail
crash
a company whose management has been
black was blacklisted
because uh it uh because it blacklisted
trade union
activists and still faces legal actions
from some unions
and the company which in 2019 was
suspended
for from bidding for government work
because it consistently made payments to
small and medium-sized
businesses late is that sort of company
that labor wants to see getting the work
because it's got a union jack on its
website trevor
it wouldn't be me as chancellor leaning
on public bodies to award contracts what
it is about
is changing the procurement framework so
you can take into account
labor standards job creation in this
country and
environmental standards as well so there
is a level playing field
for businesses doing business in this
country and we take into account the
whole value
of the bids including the impact it
would have
on the environment on labour standards
and on jobs in this country
as i say under w2sto rules
under the trade agreement that we did
with our european partners last year
these things are possible
other countries do it because they know
it is strategically important
we should as well and that would ensure
that we create
more good jobs for small businesses and
large businesses
here in britain and that is the right
thing to do
it's not what is happening at the moment
in a whole range of government contracts
whether it is
offshore wind or hs2 or trident
submarines
we need to do things differently because
we have to grow the industries of the
future and ensure that there are more
good quality high paid jobs in every
corner of our country
and as chancellor of the exchequer i
would use every tool at my disposal
to ensure that the uk economy is firing
on all cylinders
and creating more good quality jobs that
you can raise the family on
just so one very quick last question
this is your first
big announcement says shadow chancellor
your predecessor uh john mcdonnell said
that you can't understand
capitalism without reading karl marx's
dash capital have you had that privilege
i haven't trevor had that privilege of
um reading
it but i studied economics for my degree
and for my master's degree i've worked
for many years
at the bank of england at the british
embassy in washington as an economist
and for halifax bank of scotland so
i hope my credentials speak for
themselves and as chancellor
i would do things differently but always
ensuring
that our policies are costed that they
add up
and that they are in the best interests
of the british people
okay i'm sure mr mcdonald's got a spare
copy to lend you if you
want it rachel reeves thank you very
much
thank you trevor we are now just over a
fortnight away from july the 19th the
day on which the government still seemed
determined to remove
most remaining covert restrictions in
england
with 85 percent of adults having been
given one dose of a vaccine and nearly
two-thirds having received
both doses the link between case numbers
and hospitalization
appears to have been broken or has it
well the pediatrician adam finn is a
member of the joint committee on
vaccination and immunisation
which advises the government on its
vaccine's policy he joined us from
coimbra in
portugal um dr finn
are we on the on track for the end of
lockdown do you think
it's a really difficult question to
answer to be quite honest
uh the the rate of rise of cases is very
substantial at the moment
uh of course there is very clear
evidence that the
vaccination program has massively
reduced the number of
hospitalizations and deaths but they are
nevertheless going up
right across the country um and that i
guess is the
the critical uh the critical factor that
determines whether or not
uh uh things can normalize um
so yes who knows i i guess uh
we are in a very uh unusual
unprecedented situation
and uh it's very tricky to give you a
straight answer
well um we heard from robert generic
uh the housing secretary a little
earlier some noises that
seem to suggest that we're heading in
that direction but um are you
sympathetic to the
bma's case that even if we do open up
there should be
some restrictions for example the
maintenance of mask discipline
and so on well on a personal level i
shall certainly be continuing to wear a
mask
if i've got any symptoms or if i'm in an
enclosed face with
lots of other people for a prolonged
period of time indefinitely in fact
because i've learned that by doing that
i can reduce the risk of transmission of
all sorts
indefinitely yeah yeah absolutely i
think
we learned as pediatricians we learned
that we can avoid
massive problems with children getting
sick in the winter by doing these kind
of measures we we simply didn't see the
epidemics of
respiratory viruses last winter that
we've seen every year
throughout my career so i actually now
completely understand it
whereas i was puzzled before when i saw
asian people in the tube wearing masks
in the pre-pandemic era so
i think mask wearing is is obviously
something we've learned
is extremely valuable to do under
certain circumstances that doesn't mean
i'll wear a mask all the time
but it does mean i will some of the time
well if we're thinking about return to
normality
once some of your scientific colleagues
worry that daily publication
of data on deaths and infections and
hospitalizations and so forth
are essentially panicking people rather
than reassuring them
do you think it's time to stop the
publication of that data at least with
that frequency
uh well i actually think that it's
important to share
information with people i think the
moment you stop doing that
you run the risk of people not trusting
you anymore to
to explain the actions that you're
taking so certainly in the area where
i'm
involved in advising the government
which is around vaccination
uh we're very transparent with the data
and the evidence that we
use to to drive those recommendations
um of course i think when you provide
information you need to explain it
uh it doesn't really make any sense to
just give numbers without
explaining what the implications are but
i'm not really in favor of suppressing
information no
the health secretary this morning is
saying that we need to learn to accept
covid and treat it essentially as
the same as flu well each year
according to the ons we uh
see something like 20 22 000 deaths
from flu um do you
accept that that actually that is what
we're going to have to live with now
it's inevitable
uh it looks very likely that this
coronavirus like the others before it
will be with us
for the long term um i think in the
short term
exactly what it does and how much
trouble it causes around the world
looks pretty daunting uh in the longer
term i think it it remains with us
and just how benign it becomes over time
is a matter of speculation
uh but but yes i don't think we're going
to see this virus disappear i think it's
going to
join all the others that cause trouble
for us every year
and we are going to have to learn to
live with it in the longer term yes
so more excess deaths would um the
i know you can't preempt jcvi decisions
but um do you expect therefore for
people
to uh receive a booster vaccination
to add to the regular flu vaccination
each year
uh well certainly we've made
recommendations in the last week to
uh if you like provide us a sense of
direction as to how a program like that
would look
and who would be targeted for boosters
if it proves necessary
i don't think it's absolutely uh 100
sure that we need to do that but i think
we need to be prepared for the
possibility
uh particularly if we begin to see signs
of waning
vaccine protection or escape from the
protection that we've got from the
vaccines as the back as the virus
evolves
so we need to be ready to to do a
booster program if it if we need to
so you are worried about a fourth wave
or not
worried about a fourth wave okay you
mean one after this one
uh i i think i'm most worried really
about
the the global situation uh there are
obviously countries where they're in
fourth and fifth waves now
um and i'm worried about that not just
out of a sense
of um fairness for the people around the
world but actually also for us in the uk
we've had this experience in the last
two months
of importation of a much more infectious
virus
from india that will happen again if the
pandemic goes forward unchecked around
the world and will be left in
in a worse problem and i think that's
the most likely scenario to cause a
fourth or fifth wave
in this country that would be out of
control
adam finn thank you very much indeed
thank you
so jeffrey john donaldson was officially
confirmed as the democratic unionist
party's latest leader this week
it's third in just two months in his
first speech as leader
jeffrey insisted the only path to stable
and sustainable government
includes the removal of the irish sea
border
and earth unity against the brexit deals
northern ireland protocol
which effectively imposed it but the
unity he seeks seems
some way off with the resignation of a
dup storm and assembly member
onto jeffrey's first day in charge
well in his first television interview
since becoming leader sir jeffrey
donaldson spoke to our senior island
correspondent
david blevins about how to tread the
tricky path ahead
and his concerns about rising tension on
the streets of northern ireland
sir jeffrey you have said the removal of
the protocol is the only path to stable
government in northern ireland
what if it isn't removed well at the
heart of the
belfast or good friday agreement um are
three sets of relationships and there's
a very delicate balance within that
agreement as to how
those relationships are managed and one
of the key relationships is that between
northern ireland
and great britain and the agreement is
very clear the principle of consent
protects the right of the people
of northern ireland to determine their
constitutional status
when you harm one of those relationships
you harm
all of them by extension and that's
exactly what we have seen happening
because our relationship with great
britain has been harmed by this protocol
so too our relationship with the
republic of ireland has been harmed and
indeed
it has undermined and destabilized
relationships
within northern itself and we've seen
that even on our streets so
it is imperative for all of us that we
resolve these issues i'm not
accepting that this can't be done i'm
not accepting
that there is no solution i believe
there is and that's what i'm going to
strive for
and i'm not going to contemplate failure
you talk about the tension
on the streets the dup says the
government is aware and is listening to
the concerns
but this is the same government that
promised your party there would never be
an irish sea border so why should the
loyalists who are protesting trust this
government
well i understand their skepticism i
really do
um we've heard the prime minister even
in recent weeks
talk about uh addressing the issues and
the problems created by the protocol
we've heard him recognize that there um
there are difficulties in terms of the
relationship between great britain and
northern ireland but not just in trading
terms the prime minister
also needs to recognize that this
impacts on
our constitutional position i'm prepared
always to give people a second chance
and i'm prepared to give the prime
minister an opportunity now to put right
what was done wrong to northern ireland
under the protocol
but there are those who would say it's
time for the dup to put right
the wrong of promoting a brexit that was
going to require a border somewhere
is it perhaps time to look at the
positive
to promote the benefits of having access
to the eu market
and the gb market i believe there are
opportunities going forward
but we can't get to those opportunities
because of these unnecessary barriers
much of our supply chain comes from
great britain
whether you are a consumer buying goods
in a supermarket
or a business relying on component parts
for
your manufacturing process we need to
fix that supply chain problem
we need to restore northern ireland
place within the uk
both the market and constitutionally and
if we can do that
then yes we will see the opportunities
that will flow
uh provided we can find practical
solutions on
trade with the eu let's talk for a
moment about
legacy we've seen another two historical
prosecutions
collapse this week you're a former
soldier so you will understand the
concerns of veterans
you're also a victim two of your cousins
were murdered during the troubles
how does northern ireland draw a line
under its difficult past is there an
alternative
to the government's proposal of a
prosecutorial amnesty
uh i think we need a a process that
moves us from where we are
to where we can finally say well look
we've examined the past
we have given people the opportunity and
to
explore whether there is the prospect of
prosecutions
against those who murdered their loved
ones um and
and then yes we need to move to the next
phase of the peace process we need to
move our society
beyond an examination of the past to the
kind of reconciliation and healing
that we desire to see in northern
ireland so
we need some form of process that
recognizes the suffering
of many the injustice that many feel in
northern ireland i don't think you can
pull a veil over that i don't think you
can ignore that
i think that if we're going to have
healing we need to have recognition and
acknowledgement
you are the dups third leader in the
space of two months
is the party imploding because of what
some would consider to be an
own goal on brexit that resulted in a
protocol
and unsettled unionism about
power sharing and the prospects for
irish unity
i don't think it is to do with brexit um
i think that
the issues that have arisen within the
dep
have multiple causes my job now my task
is to bring the party together again
and to together on our common ground
the dup believes passionately in the
union of great britain and northern
ireland we believe
passionately that northern ireland and
all of its people are best served
being part of that united kingdom we
need to broaden the appeal of unionism
and therefore we need to resolve our
internal difficulties i believe we're
well on our way now to doing that the
meeting of the party executive
um this week um saw unanimous support
for
my leadership uh it saw people
coming together acknowledging the hurt
that had been caused on both sides
of the argument and i think now we're
moving away from that
and and we've walked back from the idea
of factionalism
your deputy leader paula bradley this
week apologized
to the lgbtq plus community for what she
described as atrocious
and hurtful comments made by some
elected representatives from the party
in the past
do you share her regret about that and
how will you address any repeat of those
comments
well i think it is true and it's not
just in the case of the dup that things
have been said in the past that have
been hurtful to
people and i think it's right when that
happens that
we say sorry and acknowledge that hurt
equally i hope in time others will be
able to acknowledge that they have
caused hurt
uh for example to people from a strongly
held faith perspective
david the kind of northern ireland i
want is one where we can have respect
for difference
um and in terms of looking ahead i hope
uh that my colleagues will recognize
that when we
take decisions about social issues uh
when we speak out
on social issues which we are entitled
to do that we do so in a gracious way
that we avoid language language that is
seen as intemperate
um or disrespectful but where that
happens i will not hesitate to
ensure that it doesn't happen again
thank you very much for your time
sir jeffrey donaldson with david blevins
there and now
one of the political world's most
well-known oracles
the american pollster and communications
strategist frank luntz is best known for
his analysis of american politics
he hit the headlines earlier this year
when he declared that he'd had enough of
donald trump and the republican party
but he's always retained a keen interest
in uk politics too
ever since advising boris johnson on his
campaign for the presidency of the
oxford union
35 years ago now lunz has undertaken the
survey of this nation for the center for
policy studies
focusing on language and attitudes
towards political
and economic issues and is here to
discuss those findings ahead of the
survey's
full publication later this week
franklin
what were you actually trying to
understand with this survey
well in three words populism locism
and extremism i've seen the damage
that's done to american politics to the
american economy
and i want to see that happen here in
the uk i spent three years at oxford in
the 1980s
i was recently a lecturer for a week at
the vodmic institute at oxford
and i loved it i really do love it here
and i appreciate the civility and the
decency that people
exhibit i appreciate the respect that
they have for different points of view
and it's in essence a warning a wake-up
call
and and a road map for how to avoid the
mess
that we've got in america right now and
i say this on the fourth of july and it
really disappoints me
because i still love my country and i'm
still
i'm still patriotic i still get
emotional when i see the flag
but i get emotional when i see your flag
as well the union jack
and i want to see understanding i want
to see respect i want to see civility
across the political spectrum
so that's why i'm here and that's the
purpose of the cps study
well we were talking earlier on the
program about that issue and we just had
a by-election i think you'll know here
where uh i have to say it wasn't
particularly
um characterized by civility but let's
have a look at the whole picture
let's start with um what people think
about um
political leaders in britain you ask a
question about how political leaders
make people feel
and look at that that's the number one
answer we gave them a list of 18
attributes and disappointed came in
first ignored irrelevant
the first eight words we gave them ten
negative words and eight positive words
and the first eight that they chose were
all negative
that this is a wake-up call for the
conservatives for lib dems for labor for
the greens it's a wake-up call for
everyone in politics
that the public isn't hearing you that
you may be
speaking you may be doing events you may
be sending them emails and text you may
have a website
but to them it's all noise you need to
cut through the clutter and i'm going to
give you three
recommendations for it number one is
that they want to know what you are for
not what you are against so don't define
yourself by the other party define
yourself
by yours number two the highest priority
right now is honesty and trust so be
candid with them
say what you mean and mean what you say
and number three
safety security strong uh successful
that the number one focus is still the
economy
but number two right underneath it and
right behind it is crime
so give people a better quality of life
and they'll give you
a re-election that's um
well that's that's quite a big steer for
us as a programmer it sounds like
we'd um do better in ratings if we had
fewer politicians on bit of a problem
for us but
the the point you make there about
division which we again we discussed
earlier on
um in the united states we see a lot of
division on the
issues of race and so on uh is that
reflected here what's the greatest
divide that we're seeing in britain
today
the number one divide is by wealth it's
by
income inequality we've got the same
child challenge in the states even the
conservatives
who talk about economic freedom even
they
prioritize rich versus poor as
uh as the number two behind uh
british born versus immigrants but
overall
the rich versus poor divine and by the
way this is a warning for the
conservatives
that they need to understand and reflect
the public's feeling that nobody
succeeds
if everyone doesn't succeed that this
idea of every and all
is essential every person needs a shot
at success every person in every
community
needs a shot at a ladder up the
opportunity to succeed
it's not the definition of what happens
at the end that matters
they're not asking for equal outcomes
which is
a labor challenge but they are asking
for equal opportunity they're asking for
a healthy economy
an open economy and they're asking that
they be respected
as hard-working taxpayers that's
interesting
because um you know that's clear and
that's a traditional
divide in this country but we hear a lot
of noise about what
people these days call culture wars the
issues
of race of uh religion religion and
religious fundamentalism and all of that
and um this relatively new word which
other surveys recently here suggests
nobody really
or most people don't really know what it
means wokism
what are we following america in our
obsession with that or is it something
it's not going to matter to us i think
it's going to matter deeply it doesn't
matter right now but it's coming
there are many ways that america follows
the uk
uh your vote from president was an
indication of a hidden vote
that that donald trump took advantage of
your vote for margaret thatcher back 40
years ago
was the leading indicator for ronald
reagan and there are times when america
is ahead of you such as bill clinton to
tony blair and right now
woke-ism cancel culture uh
the the language is mean and harsh
and the outcome will be negative as as
you've got right up there the
conservatives are deeply afraid of
rocism
labor is more afraid of racism even
though one third of your country does
not know what wokism is
it's still the number three consumer
the number three ism and here's why they
know that it's divisive they know that
it's polarizing they know that it's not
being put
forward to have a better uh more unified
country which is what the
cps study is all about it's about unity
woke-ism is about division about
polarization about punishing people for
success
and not respecting hard work and
meritocracy and by the way i don't know
if you've got this data
but to my surprise people put equality
over meritocracy now i need to give a
proviso
inequality is unacceptable in 2021 uk
and 2021 u.s equality
uh a discrimination that we expect
everyone
everywhere to have that opportunity and
we want that opportunity to be available
to everyone based on hard work
creativity and outcome so
i would think that we would want to
cherish meritocracy but right now
equality is a higher priority to the
british population
one of the um that's interesting one of
the outputs of the
if you like this the concern about these
issues of workers and so on as
what's called council culture i people's
essentially having the right to free
expression deprived
um what what do we think about that we
think that freedom of speech is the
number one
freedom we believe that freedom of
speech freedom of expression
so nobody wants to cancel rallies nobody
wants to limit
protests it's a very very small
percentage
of the uk population but they want to
ensure
that those who work hard play by the
rules pay their
taxes that they're respected not
punished and you'll see a big difference
between conservative voters and labor
voters
on this issue of cancer culture and in
fact on every issue
we have a divide in america personally
and the way we treat each other
that divide is not as great in the uk
however
the uk political policy divisions
priority divisions
are even wider than the us and i will
tell you from personal experience here
on the fourth of july on a day
that i should be celebrating by going to
fireworks and having burgers and
and coleslaw and just celebrating
independence
it's very hard to celebrate because we
are so mean
and so ugly and so rotten to each other
the language that we would not
accept our kids using is language that
politicians use against each other every
day in america
and they don't want to see that in the
uk we've been conducting focus groups
with cps
and and the responses people are
respectful and decent and disagree with
each other in a positive way
that's the kind of politics you want to
practice that's the kind of politics we
should be doing in america
and i want to ensure that that kind of
politics stays in the uk forever
uh i want you to say it on on
independence day but maybe the the brits
have something to teach the americans
about being
nice and and civil uh but by the way one
one um
of the results which i thought was very
interesting is that we don't just have a
low opinion of politicians but also
to some extent of british uh of business
leaders
um and there's a i think you've got a
result about
what we think business leaders ought to
be doing
yes and the one thing that's a shock to
me is that
climate in this country is now universal
that this is the only country where
arguably more people on the right are
environmentalists
and are focused on issues of climate
than people on the left
it's not happening anywhere else in the
globe but it is happening here
this is the one area where universally
the british public says let's be
environmentally friendly
let's have a cleaner safer healthier
globe
let's put our environmental community
first
it's very impressive to see i thought
it's really interesting that actually
conservatives appear to be marginally
more concerned about business leaders
doing something on climate change than
uh labor supporters yeah but you know
where we got universal agreement
the business community should stay out
of politics
they want business to focus on business
focus on employees focus
on their employees not workers and by
the way they're no longer businesses
they're employers because the british
public is so much more supportive of
those
who who create jobs than they are of
that company itself
and they want customers they want to
focus
on on employees and not
on shareholders and what's interesting
is investor
is so much more supported than a
shareholder because a shareholder
is just about making money and investors
making a personal commitment
in that in that business and that
employer and in the future
so we have a whole business lexicon that
will be helpful
to uh to those involved in the british
economy and believe me
they need to use it because right now
the business community also
has some credibility issues frank you
need to spend more time with us we are
basically so nice and lovely and polite
on this side of
the water um and be good to see more of
you
frankly i don't want to go home i want
to stay here but uh
i need to leave in a few weeks but thank
you once again even your interview
on sky is more civil than what we have
in the u.s so i appreciate it
thank you very much well that's it for
now after the break we'll be talking
about what we've learned
on this morning's programme with our
deputy political editor
sam coates
[Music]
you